so we were actually debating a little
bit about what's going on with the Bud
Light stuff but I think I would defer to
you as someone who actually knows how to
ship sell and deal with beer and you
actually have a calendar of conservative
beautiful women that you just put out so
I I'll save it for the show but uh I
mean you you've also done other things
in the past with uh wrapping paper right
right uh well we're I'm all beer all the
time now it's um it's it's a lot it's a
heavy regulation business but there's
there's a huge market for again it's is
parallel economy stuff and like why are
we giving money to companies that hate
us and they're taking our hard-earned
money and they're putting it into causes
that we hate and so I just I sitting
there and see like and look there's we
can't do that with every single product
look my house is filled with products
made in communist China I don't want
that but there's a lot not a lot of
options there is now an option for an
americanmade beer an American-owned beer
as well let's go